Un enfant est né
et pendant un long moment
il est un consommateur.
Il ne peut pas être consciemment un contributeur.
Il est sans défense.
Il ne sait même pas comment survivre,
même s’il est doué d'un instinct de survie.
Il a besoin de l'aide d'une mère, ou d'une mère adoptive, pour survivre.
Il ne peut pas se permettre de douter de la personne qui s'en occupe.
Il doit complètement se rendre,
comme on se rend à un anesthésiste.
Il doit complètement se rendre.
Cela demande beaucoup de confiance.
Ce qui signifie que cette personne de confiance
ne violera pas cette confiance.
Au fur et à mesure que l'enfant grandit,
il commence à découvrir
que la personne de confiance est en train de violer cette confiance.
Il ne connaît même pas le mot violation.
Il doit par conséquent s'en prendre à lui-même.
Un blâme muet,
qui est plus difficile à résoudre complètement,
le blâme muet contre soi-même.
Au fur et à mesure que l'enfant grandit et devient un adulte,
jusque là il a été un consommateur,
mais la croissance d'un être humain,
réside dans sa capacité de contribuer,
d'être un contributeur.
On ne peut pas contribuer tant qu'on ne se sent pas en confiance,
on se sent grand,
on sent: J'ai assez.
Avoir de la compassion n'est pas une plaisanterie.
Ce n'est pas si simple.
On doit découvrir une certaine grandeur en soi-même.
Cette grandeur devrait être centrée sur soi-même,
pas en termes d'argent,
pas en termes du pouvoir que vous exercez,
pas dans les termes d'un statut que vous pouvez inspirer dans la société,
mais il devrait être centré sur soi-même.
Le moi, vous êtes conscient de vous-même.
Sur ce moi, il doit être centré, une grandeur, une intégrité,
sinon, la compassion n'est qu'un mot et un rêve.
Vous pouvez être compatissant occasionnellement,
plus ému par l'empathie
que par la compassion.
Grâce à Dieu nous sommes empathiques.
Quand quelqu'un souffre, nous souffrons aussi.
Dans un match à Wimbledon, une finale,
ces deux hommes se battent.
Chacun a deux jeux.
Ça peut être le jeu de n'importe qui.
Ce pour quoi ils ont transpiré jusqu'à maintenant n'a pas de sens.
Une personne gagne.
La bienséance du tennis dit que les deux joueurs doivent aller au filet
et se serrer la main.
Le gagnant boxe dans les airs
et embrasse le sol,
lance son maillot comme si quelqu'un l'attendait.
(Rires)
Et ce gars doit aller au filet.
Quand il arrive au filet,
vous le voyez, l'expression de son visage change complètement.
On dirait qu'il aimerait ne pas avoir gagné.
Pourquoi? L'empathie.
C'est la nature de l'homme.
Aucun homme de coeur n'est exempt de cette empathie.
Aucune religion ne peut démolir ça par l'endoctrinement.
Aucune culture, aucune nation, aucun nationalisme,
rien ne peut le toucher
car c'est l'empathie.
Et cette capacité d'empathie
est la fenêtre par laquelle vous atteignez les gens,
vous faites quelque chose qui change la vie de quelqu'un.
Même des mots, même du temps.
La compassion n'est pas définie par une seule forme.
Il n'y a pas de compassion indienne.
Il n'y a pas de compassion américaine.
Elle transcende les pays, les sexes, les âges.
Pourquoi? Car elle est là en chacun de nous.
Elle est vécue occasionnellement par les gens.
Alors, ce n'est pas de compassion occasionnelle,
que nous parlons ici.
Elle ne restera jamais occasionnelle.
Par mandat, vous ne pouvez pas rendre une personne pleine de compassion.
Vous ne pouvez pas dire, "Aimez-moi s'il vous plaît."
L'amour est quelque chose que vous découvrez.
Ce n'est pas une action,
mais dans la langue anglaise, c'est aussi une action.
J'y reviendrai plus tard.
Donc chacun doit découvrir une certaine intégrité.
Je vais citer les possibilités d'être entier,
ce qui est à la portée de notre expérience, de l'expérience de chacun.
En dépit d'une vie très tragique,
chacun est heureux pendant des moments qui sont très courts et éloignés les uns des autres.
Et celui qui est heureux,
même pour une blague potache,
s'accepte lui-même, et aussi l'ordre des choses dans lequel chacun se trouve.
Ce qui veut dire l'univers tout entier,
les choses connues et les choses inconnues.
Elles sont toutes acceptées
parce que vous découvrez votre intégrité en vous-même.
Le sujet, moi,
et l'objet, l'ordre des choses,
fusionnons pour ne faire qu'un,
une expérience dont personne ne peut dire, "j'en suis exempt,"
une expérience commune à tout un chacun.
Cette expérience confirme que, malgré toutes vos limites,
tous vos besoins, désirs, inaccomplis, et les cartes de crédit,
et les licenciements,
et, pour finir, la calvitie,
vous pouvez être heureux.
Mais l'extension de la logique est
que vous n'avez pas besoin de satisfaire vos désirs pour être heureux.
Vous êtes le bonheur même, l'intégrité, que vous voulez être.
Il n'y a pas de choix dans cela.
Cela ne fait que confirmer la réalité
que le tout ne peut être différent de vous,
ne peut pas être sans vous.
Il doit être vous.
Vous ne pouvez pas faire partie du tout
et être quand même être complet.
Votre moment de bonheur révèle cette réalité,
cette réalisation, cette reconnaissance.
Peut-être que je suis le tout.
Peut-être que le swami a raison.
Peut-être que le swami a raison. Vous démarrez une nouvelle vie.
Alors tout prend sens.
Je n'ai plus de raison de me blâmer.
Si l'on veut se blâmer, on a des millions de raisons plus beaucoup d'autres,
mais si je dis, malgré mon corps limité,
s’il est noir, il n'est pas blanc, s’il est blanc il n'est pas noir,
le corps est limité quelle que soit la manière dont vous le regardez.Limité.
Votre connaissance est limitée, la santé est limitée,
et le pouvoir est par conséquent limité,
et la bonne humeur va être limitée.
La compassion va être limitée.
Tout va être illimité.
Vous ne pouvez pas commander la compassion
sauf si vous devenez illimité, et personne ne peut devenir illimité,
ou vous l'êtes ou vous ne l’êtes pas. Point.
Et vous n'avez aucun moyen non plus de ne pas être illimité.
Votre propre expérience révèle, en dépit de toutes les limites, que vous êtes le tout.
Et le fait d'être le tout est votre réalité
lorsque vous vous rapportez au monde.
C'est l'amour en premier.
Lorsque vous vous rapportez au monde,
la manifestation dynamique de l'intégrité
c'est, comme nous disons, l'amour.
Et il devient lui-même compassion
si l'objet auquel il se rapporte évoque cette émotion.
Alors de nouveau ça se transforme en don, et en partage.
Vous vous exprimez, car vous avez de la compassion.
Pour découvrir la compassion, vous devez être compatissant.
Pour découvrir la capacité de donner et de partager,
vous devez donner et partager.
Il n'y a pas de raccourci. C'est comme nager en nageant.
Vous apprenez à nager en nageant.
Vous ne pouvez pas apprendre à nager sur un matelas de mousse et ensuite entrer dans l'eau.
(Rires)
Vous apprenez à nager en nageant. Vous apprenez à faire du vélo en faisant du vélo.
Vous apprenez à cuisiner en cuisinant,
en ayant des personnes sympathiques autour de vous
pour manger ce que vous avez cuisiné.
(Rires)
Et, donc, ce que je dis,
c'est que vous devez faire semblant de faire, et le faire.
(Rires)
Vous devez vraiment.
Mon prédécesseur voulait dire cela.
Vous devez le réaliser.
Vous devez agir avec compassion.
Il n'y a pas de verbe pour la compassion,
mais il y a un adverbe pour la compassion.
Je trouve ça intéressant.
Vous agissez avec compassion.
Mais alors, comment agir avec compassion si vous n'avez pas de compassion?
C'est là que vous devez faire semblant.
Vous faites semblant et vous le faites. C'est le mantra des États-Unis d'Amérique.
(Rires)
Vous faites semblant, et vous le faites.
Vous agissez avec compassion, comme si vous aviez de la compassion,
grincez des dents,
prenez tout le système de support,
si vous savez prier, priez.
Réclamez la compassion.
Laissez-moi agir avec compassion.
Faites-le
Vous découvrirez la compassion
et alors doucement une compassion relative,
et doucement, peut-être si vous recevez le bon enseignement,
vous découvrirez que la compassion est une manifestation dynamique
de la réalité de soi-même, qui est l'unité, l'intégrité,
et c'est ce que vous êtes.
Sur ces mots, merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)